james michael tyler has died he was 59.
i went in on the first extra call a
friend of mine bleached my hair
and they liked the look
and they kept me for 10 years
what's my last name
central perk
the french star's death follows a
three-year battle with stage four
prostate cancer in a statement a rep for
james says the actor died peacefully at
his los angeles home on sunday james is
survived by his wife jennifer carnell
i'm sorry to say that i'm
not appearing today with you to announce
that there's going to be a friends movie
james opened up about his diagnosis for
the first time earlier this year
actually i'm here to
let you know that in september of 2018
i was diagnosed with
advanced to prostate cancer
which had spread to my bones
the actor was best known for playing
gunther on friends the cast's go-to
barista at central perk no no it's okay
right gunther
don't wink at me
james took part in the friends reunion
special for hbo max in may ladies and
gentlemen please welcome james michael
tyler
it was the most memorable uh 10 years of
my life
honestly i i could not have imagined
just a better
experience all these guys were fantastic
it was just a joy to work with them the
following month james revealed why he
appeared virtually for the special
you know i didn't want to be like oh and
by the way gunther has cancer you know
what i mean my goal this past year
was to see my 59th birthday
i did that he went on to say that
promoting prostate cancer awareness was
his life's new mission
next time you go in for just a basic
exam or your yearly checkup please
ask your doctor for a psa test over the
years james opened up to e.t about
becoming part of the friends phenomenon
do you remember back in the audition and
all that was there an audition um no i
actually uh started as an extra so for a
year and a half i was coffee guy it was
a happy accident i should say what's
your birthday
may 5th why oh i i'm just making a list
of people's birthdays oh mine's december
yeah whatever
[Music]
yeah i guess i just had like the right
weird hair and uh and just kind of fit
in the in the coffee house so
uh kind of like the guy behind the
counter and they eventually kind of
expanded upon that
it's hard to get through a day sometimes
i mean because people are they forget
okay we gotta get to work now you know
let's stop joking around probably my
number one favor there was an episode
where um they had rachel um was doing
the crossword puzzle i did it
i finished it i did it all by myself
and there's nobody to hug
another one would be um a recent one
actually which was basically just a
reaction shot that uh
when
schwimmer ross gets punched by joey
gumper gets this huge big grin
we had a hard time getting through that
one when a fist comes at your face you
duck look
oh
what is the matter with you
it's a blast it's like the best time of
my life
[Music]